>>> COLLECTIVE BARGAINING WORKS.
THAT'S THE MESSAGE THIS MORNING
FROM PRESIDENT BIDEN.
HIS FIRST REACTION TO THE
TENTATIVE DEAL STRUCK AFTER THE
LONGEST ACTORS STRIKE EVER
AGAINST THE HOLLYWOOD STUDIOS.
THE WALKOUT LASTED 118 DAYS.
IT COST THE ECONOMY THOUSANDS OF
JOBS AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WITH 160,000 ACTORS ESSENTIALLY
FORCED TO HIT THE PAUSE BUTTON
ON THE WORK AND CURRENT
PROJECTS.
HERE IS MORE OF A STATEMENT FROM
PRESIDENT BIDEN THIS MORNING.
HE SAYS WHEN BOTH SIDES COME TO
THE TABLE TO NEGOTIATE IN
EARNEST THEY CAN MAKE BUSINESSES
STRONGER.
HERE IS WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE
DEAL.
THE ACTORS HAVE LOCKED IN WAGE
INCREASES THAT HAVEN'T BEEN SEEN
IN 40 YEARS.
STREAMING COMPENSATION TO A NEW
LEVEL.
A.I. IS INCLUDED IN THE DEAL
WHICH HAS NEVER BEEN MENTIONED
BEFORE IN AN ACTOR'S DEAL.
NOW, WE WILL TALK MUCH MORE
ABOUT THIS, AND WE ARE JOINED BY
THE PRESIDENT OF SAG-AFTRA FRAN
DRESCHER WHICH YOU HAVE SLEPT
NONE, BECAUSE OF THESE LONG
HARD-FOUGHT NEGOTIATIONS THAT
HAVE LASTED SO LONG.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
HOW DO YOU FEEL THIS MORNING AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY, WHAT IS THE
MESSAGE THAT YOU HAVE TO YOUR
MEMBERS?
>> WELL, HOW I FEEL IS GREAT
RELIEF AND HAPPINESS THAT WE
STOOD FIRM, WE HELD OUR GROUND,
AND WE GOT A HISTORIC AND
SEMINEL CONTRACT AT A POINT IN
HISTORY THAT WAS NECESSARY.
AND WHAT IS THE OTHER QUESTION?
>> YOUR MESSAGE TO MEMBERS THIS
MORNING.
>> OH, YOU KNOW, I FEEL LIKE I'M
GRATEFUL THAT THEY HUNG IN.
I'M APPRECIATIVE THEY SHOWED THE
SUPPORT THEY DID FOR OUR
NEGOTIATING COMMITTEE, ALL OF
THE STAFF, EVERYBODY WORKING SO
HARD, RIDING SIDE BY SIDE.
AND DUNCAN CRABTREE IS JUST A
GIFT.
IT IS JUST THAT WE CAN REALLY
CELEBRATE WITH THIS CONTRACT.
I'M ALREADY THINKING ABOUT THE
THINGS THAT I WANT TO GET IN THE
NEXT CONTRACT THAT WE DIDN'T GET
IN THIS CONTRACT, BUT WE BROKE
SO MUCH GROUND.
THERE IS SO MUCH LANGUAGE IN
THIS CONTRACT THAT COVERS SO
MUCH NEW GROUND THAT HAS NEVER
BEEN IN ANY OTHER CONTRACT
BEFORE.
THAT WAS THE POINT OF THIS
NEGOTIATION, TO BREAK A LOT OF
NEW GROUND.
WE DID.
AND OF COURSE, WE CROSSED THE
BILLION DOLLAR MARK.
THAT, TOO, IS HISTORIC.
WE PASSED WITHOUT OBJECTION, AND
>> IT STILL NEEDS TO BE RATIFIED
BY THE UNION MEMBER, AND I
ASSUME YOU SAY NO, BECAUSE YOU
ARE LOOKING TO THE NEXT
CONTRACT, BUT ANY QUESTION THAT
IT IS NOT GOING TO GO THROUGH?
>> NO, NO.
NOT REALLY.
BECAUSE IT HAS TO GO TO THE
BOARD WHICH IS GOING TO APPROVE
IT TOMORROW MORNING, AND THEN
FROM THERE WE GET THE MEMBER
BODY TO RATIFY IT, AND I FEEL
LIKE IT IS SUCH A GOOD CONTRACT
AND OUR LOWEST PAID, YOU KNOW,
MEMBERS WHO ARE IN BACKGROUND,
THEY GOT AN UNBELIEVABLE DEAL.
AND OUR EXPERT FROM THAT
COMMUNITY SAID THEY NEVER FELT
SO REPRESENTED, AND NEVER SEEN,
AND HE'S BEEN IN SEVEN CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS NEVER SEEN HIS
COMMUNITY FOUGHT SO HARD FOR.
THEY GOT AN INCREDIBLE DEAL.
IT IS NOT OVER.
AND IT IS NEVER OVER WITH
CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS, BUT IT IS
HISTORIC AND WE GOT SO MUCH, SO
MUCH IMPORTANT STUFF.
AND IMPROVEMENTS FINANCIALLY IN
SO MANY DIFFERENT PLACES THAT I
FEEL LIKE WE ALL IN OUR
NEGOTIATING COMMITTEE SLEPT MUCH
BETTER LAST NIGHT THAN WE HAVE
IN MONTHS, BECAUSE WE HAVE ALL
FELT THE WEIGHT OF
RESPONSIBILITY OF THIS STRIKE
AND NEEDED A WHOLE LOT OF
FORTITUDE TO SEE IT ALL OF THE
WAY TO THE POINT WHERE WE SAID
WE CAN CSENO CAUSE THE MOST IMP
THING --
>> LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THE ROAD
AHEAD, BECAUSE IN THIS STRIKE
AND IN THE NEGOTIATIONS, I HEARD
YOU CALL THE STUDIOS TONE DEAF,
GREEDY, AND IN THE WAY THEY WERE
OPERATING DISGUSTING.
THE ALLIANCE REPRESENTING THE
STUDIOS SAYS THAT AFTER THIS,
THE AMPTP IS PLEASED TO HAVE
REACHED A TENTATIVE AGREEMENT,
AND LOOKS FORWARD TO THE
INDUSTRY TELLING GREAT STORIES.
SO WHAT ABOUT THE RELATIONSHIP
OF THE STUDIOS AND THE ACTORS
AND WHAT DO YOU SAY ABOUT THE
RELATIONSHIP TODAY?
>> I THINK IT IS GOING TO BE
BUSINESS AS USUAL AND ZERO
PROBLEM.
YOU CAN NEVER TAKE THESE THINGS
PERSONALLY.
AS FREDRICK DOUGLASS SAID POWER
CONCEDES NOTHING WITHOUT DEMAND,
IT NEVER HAS AND NEVER WILL, AND
THE DEMANDS WERE MADE AND MET.
I'M VERY GRATEFUL THAT, YOU
KNOW, WHAT WE FELT AND WHAT WE
SAID IGNITED A WORKERS MOVEMENT
AROUND THE WORLD.
IT RANG LIKE A CLEAR BELL TONE
AND IT LANDED IN THE EARS OF THE
AMTPT, AND THEY HEARD IT AND MET
THE MOMENT.
>> A.I., AND I AM INTERESTED IN
THIS ASPECT OF THE DEAL, WHICH
HAS NEVER BEEN MENTIONED BEFORE
IN THE DEAL, AND IS THIS
REQUIRED IN THE MOST IMPORTANT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THERE WAS NOTHING IN THE
CONTRACT THAT, YOU KNOW, WAS
CONSENT.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO ASK FOR
PERMISSION FOR ANYTHING.
AND NOW THEY HAVE TO ASK FOR
PERMISSION FOR EVERYTHING.
AND THE LAST PIECE WAS PUT IN
PLACE VERY LATE IN THE EVENING
THE NIGHT BEFORE WE, YOU KNOW,
WE PASSED WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THE MOTION TO ACCEPT THE
CONTRACT AND END THE STRIKE.
>> I HAVE HEARD MEDIA WATCHERS
AND MEDIA REPORTS AND ANALYSTS
DESCRIBE IT THIS WAY THAT THE
ACTORS UNION, YOU ALL GOT A LOT,
AND THE STUDIOS ESSENTIALLY GOT
VERY LITTLE OTHER THAN THE
ABILITY TO GET BACK TO WORK.
DO YOU SEE IT THAT WAY?
>> WELL, THEY CERTAINLY GOT
EVERYTHING THAT WE DIDN'T GET.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU KNOW.
IT IS A NEGOTIATION.
THEY ARE GOING TO WINSOME TIMES.
AND SOMETIMES ACCEPT WHERE
HISTORY IS AND WHAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN.
THEY MAY NOT HAVE WANTED TO, YOU
KNOW, BECAUSE WE'RE THE
EMPLOYEES.
SO WHAT ARE WE GOING TO GIVE.
IT IS ALL REALLY ABOUT
UNDERSTANDING BESIDES, YOU KNOW,
OUR ART AND BEING THE BIGGEST
FOUNDATIONAL CONTRIBUTORS TO THE
WHOLE INDUSTRY, IT IS UP TO THEM
TO CONCEDE CERTAIN THINGS SO
THAT WE CAN FEEL HONORED AND
RESPECTED AND PROTECTED AND
COMPENSATED.
YOU KNOW, IT IS NEVER EASY.
BUT OVER TIME WHICH IS ALWAYS MY
SECRET SAUCE, TIME AND PATIENCE,
WE CAME TO A METING OF THE
MINDS, AND I THINK THAT THEY
WERE EXPECTING A DIFFERENT KIND
OF LEADERSHIP.
THEY WERE, YOU KNOW, IN FOR A
RUDE AWAKENING, BUT ONCE YOU
WAKE UP AND SMELL THE COFFEE, IT
IS HARD TO GO BACK TO SLEEP.
THEN WE HAD TO ROLL UP OUR
SLEEVES.
THEY KNEW THAT THEY WERE FACING
A DIFFERENT KIND OF LEADERSHIP.
THEY HAD TO LEAN IN.
>> WELL, THE SECRET SAUCE OF
TIME AND PATIENCE SEEMS TO HAVE
WORKED.
FRAN DRESCHER, THANK YOU FOR
COMING IN.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.